hi welcome to a tunnel technique class
video from my bedroom today is going to
be quite basic it's going to be for men
and women if you're a woman I recommend
you to do this without high heels so it
just you sort of flats or anything
comfortable that lets you put weight on
the whole foot on the floor it's going
to be quite basic I'm going to do every
exercise with you we will do this
together and the program is going to be
we will start with our very easy warm-up
then we will do our set of exercises to
improve our posture so for our back then
we will continue with a set of exercises
for balance which is a basic quality
that you have to work so we will get the
standing leg basically and then we'll be
finished with a set of exercises for key
words very basic because it also
connects with balance and with your
standing leg so let's start okay okay
what am I so start with your feet
together and just take a few seconds to
breathe deeply relax make sure that your
posture straight
feel the weight of your body going down
or your feet down on the floor and then
we'll start with shoulder rotations so
make sure that you only use the shoulder
yeah so then you're gonna do this with
elbows just the shoulder and we will do
10 times okay so one yes slowly two
three feel your upper back relaxing for
five six seven eight nine slowly and
then okay the next one is we will do
circles without Slammys so you start
with the arms down
you put them
front of you then you lift them up make
sure that they are straight that they
are not bent yeah I make sure that you
relax the shoulders and then you open to
the sides at this point you will feel
your chest opening stretching and then
back down yeah so we will do ten one
down to stretch the arms three relaxed
shoulders oh very nice five both are the
same
both are the same six seven okay now the
next exercise is going to be a stretch
for the torso so it's ladies first you
lift one arm and you point it up yeah
and then with this hand you slide the
front down your leg until you can touch
the side of your knee and you try to
stretch the other hand as much as you
can to the side and you hold it for
three seconds so you feel this stretch
on your side yeah and then with this
hand you pull yourself up again until
this position and then you drop down and
then you repeat the same to the other
side lift the arm slide and down the leg
until it
you're me stretch the side hold it for
three seconds and then pull yourself up
again and then go down so we will do
five times each side okay one slide down
hold it up and one to this side slide
down hold it pull up boy I was one for
more to slide down until he turns the
knee hold it up down lift the arm slide
down feels good yeah and three lift yarn
slime on your leg only three seconds and
pull up three if you're on slide down
your leg that's the meaning for the
three seconds and four down the leg hold
it up and decide up go down the leg hold
it pull up and the last time lift the
arm slide down the hole three seconds up
and decide if they are slide down the
leg hold it
okay the next exercise going to be a
rotation for your middle which is basic
for tango very important so we open the
legs we bend the knees slightly we keep
the hip on the head looking forward
during the whole exercise we make a
circle with arms not too high on the
level of your chest
yeah and then we rotate the torso ladies
yeah so we're going to do 20 yeah one
two three four
relax now five six seven eight nine ten
ten more one and two the move the hips
three four five six seven okay now we
stretch the knees and the next exercise
is going to be a stretch for the lower
back which will help with posture and
flexibility so what we do is we place
our hands behind our head we push the
elbows back and then I'm going to do it
profile so received properly first we
Bend on the hips and we go down we keep
the back straight and we'll down until
the back is parallel to the floor or
nice ladies and then we continue going
down until our head is down and then we
borrow C and three times one two three
then from here we'll recover the
straight back parallel to the floor and
then we go and this is one yeah we're
going to do ten okay so one part into
the floor go down box one two three
onto the floor and up to floor bounce
[Music]
one two three four one two three and
then part of the floor go down one two
three okay now the next one there are
only two left
next one we keep the legs open we grab
our hips with our hands and we're going
to do circles with the hip so we're
going to move to keep the head here
we're going to go back with the hip now
we're going to move the hip to the side
and then front and then to the other
side and then back yeah so we make a
complete circle be careful
their head yeah some people do these no
you are moving the head - who - move
your your hip now we're going to do ten
- its direction so one rotation will hit
two three four
slowly five six seven eight nine and
then and now which is hurt
one two three four five
make a big circle six very good seven
eight nine and ten
okay and the last one we close the legs
we bend the knees like this and then we
bounce three times one two three very
relaxed then we stretch the knees and
then we go on the ball of the foot we go
up I like to think about this exercise
like pushing the floor down we are
pushing the Florida and then we put the
heels on the floor again and then we
repeat with the bounds of minutes yeah
so we are going to do 10 times so first
one one two three stretch knees go up
all the three seconds and then now - one
two three
go up those all the three seconds go
down three one two three
stretch up
go down for one two three
strange go up go down five one two three
go up hold it go down six one two three
up hold it go down seven one two three
hold it go down eight one two three go
up hold it down 90 one two three go up
hold it go down and ten one two three go
up hold it and go down and we're
finished with the world not the next set
of exercises is going to be for our
backs for posture unequal studies you
need a wall and you put your hip on the
wall like this like you're sitting and
feet are a bit apart from the wall
otherwise it's a bit difficult I'm
shoulder apart more or less and it works
when it's first you start with the back
bent forward like this and you relax and
then the idea is to put your back on the
world starting from the lower back
better than I've ever done slowly then
you continue up your back putting it on
the wall middle of the back then
shoulder plates then chest and then the
head the head is the last thing to touch
the wall and from here you roll down
again
first is the head and then the head
pulls the rest of the back with it away
from the wall round ladies yeah at least
return to the start position
welcome to do this
yes siree studies and then roll your
back up slowly one and then rolling down
from the hip here shoulders shoulder
blades middle of the back lower the hip
don't leave
yeah this is one swing seven more slowly
[Music]
roll down onto the hip and then roll
down from here until the hip for world
up very slowly and down from head
[Music]
put your back into the world now comes
the second part of the exercise so from
this position we're going to roll up
again so hop up in the world and the
next movement is language we are going
to roll away from the wall but starting
from the hip so you keep your head on
the wall
and then you roll your hip forward like
this and then you continue up your back
until the back is away from the wall you
can leave your shoulders on and then
from this
you're going to put your back out on the
wall again where the provider Tara
starting from the shamans and finishing
on the hip okay so we're going to do it
again so from the hip one roll up the
shoulders and then roll down from the
shoulders through the Sheep to the
shooters and down three sheep three roll
up from cheek to shoulders and roll down
today for roll up to the shoulders and
then go down to the heat five
roll up to the shoulders then go down to
the heat six roll up from the Sheep
to the shoulders and then from the
shoulders three feet down seven up boom
then down to the hip and the last one
eighth row from the hip through
shoulders slowly great but this will
give you a very straight back and then
the last exercise you will need a stick
this this exercise will help you place
the shoulders in the right position
because we have the tendency to put the
shoulders forward so this will place
your shoulders up again so what how it
works you wrap the stick like this quite
wide
yeah because then they the exercise is
easier and then you put it in front of
you and then you put of your head like
this and then if you can you go all the
way down to your back yeah and then from
here again you put it above your head
and then down in front of you yeah if
you cannot go all the way then I you can
go until your limits yeah if it's like
this then it's it's good yeah every time
we practice you will be able to go a bit
further a bit further
you will be able to go all the way the
wider you grab the stick the easier it
is
if you grab the stick a bit more narrow
ladies it's a little more difficult
yeah so just find out a distance that is
comfortable for you and we are going to
do any times so one back and front and
two back three four five six seven eight
okay so that's it that's a block further
back for your posture this will improve
your embrace your posture and usually I
repeat the whole thing twice more so if
you want you can stop the video
repeat these exercises and then we'll
continue with the next vlog okay the
next step is for balance on one leg
which is really important in town and
it's a set of four exercises and I'm
going to show you all of them so the
first one I do it on the file so that
you can see it better you start with
your feet together straight posture
breathe relax like always put your
weight on one foot
this name is free the first movement is
to lift your leg your knee in front of
you the second is to extend your leg
behind you and
your toes touch the floor the third is
to put your weight on both legs and then
go down until your knee touches the
third and the last movement is to return
to this position
yeah with a knee lifted and that's a one
repetition so we're going to do eight
okay we will do it together
so one with a knee extend the leg down
to lift a knee extend the leg three
that's a floor down for keep the knee
touch the floor behind you go down
5:15 touch the floor
down up six mini that's a floor down Wow
seven if they need the floor down eight
leave the knee that's the floor down
I don't know up okay if this is too
difficult without support you can
support yourself in the world
yeah or you can take a chair there on a
chair
it's okay yeah the goal is to do it
without support now the other day so I'm
changing out my weight to the right leg
straight posture and start one if the
knee is the floor down and go up to if
the knee that's the floor down I go up
three mini extend the leg behind it
that's lower go down
what for with mini touch the floor
and go up five Guinea that's the floor
down go up six if the knee that's the
snow behind you go down go up seven if
the knee extend the leg touch the floor
go down and go up that's one eight with
the knee touch the floor behind you then
go down wait on both legs that's very
important okay that was the first
exercise the second is very similar I'm
putting my weight on the left leg again
so it starts in the same way this is the
first movement you lift the leg the
second you extend the leg behind you but
this time you don't touch the floor you
lifted food on the air yeah and the
third movement is you bend the standing
leg yeah when you do this movement make
sure that you are not going forward with
the torso don't do this yeah because
then your leg is not working so much you
have to stay straight and then bend the
knee which is more difficult and then up
and then from here you are straight into
this position again so your freedom
never touches the floor if your standing
leg working all the time so let's do
eight wish me luck
so leave one leave the knee extend the
leg bend the standing knee and stretch
- Tiffany extend the lake then instantly
state starting at 3:50 knee extend the
free leg bend standing leg stretch
studying it for books with knee stretch
behind you and stretch five-fifty knee
straight leg and stretch
sorry six if the knee extend behind you
bend the knee and stretch seven oops
this difficult lift the knee stretch
behind you bend and stretch last 150
knee 8 stretch behind you then I'm
stretch okay
oh it's hard so the other leg let's
torture the leg a little bit
eight times so put your weight on the
right leg breathe relax and then leave
the knee stretch the leg behind you bend
the leg and stretch one two lift knee
straight leg behind you bend the knee
and stretch three with the knee stays
right behind you then and stretch for
leave the knee stretch behind bend and
stretch
five fifth inning stretch behind you
then stretch six lift the knee in front
of you
stretch the right behind you then the
standing leg stretch the stomach here
seven lift extend behind you then and
stretch and eight lift extend behind you
then on stage okay good so the good news
is that the third exercise is much
easier than this it works like this you
start with open legs stretch knees and
wait in the center and then what you do
is you shift your weight to one leg then
you cross the free leg behind you and
then you put your weight on both legs
and you go down now make sure that the
weight is on both legs until your me is
on the floor and if you do it right then
it should be behind the front here okay
and then you want but and then you open
the legs again
and then you close with this leg to the
other side like this and then you put
your weight on the center and then you
go down that makes me on the floor
ideally behind this hill and then up
again and then you return to the start
position Aries so let's do eight each
side is one okay so we can spark we go
down one and we open and now one to the
other side close back weight on both
legs go down and up
this was one seven or cross back down
open this back down open three goes back
down open this back if you want you can
put your hands on your hips for cross
back go down weight on both legs go up
and open back down and open five back
down back down six happy close back down
up
open close back down open seven goes
back and down open closed back down
open last one goes back down open goes
back down open and we did eight and the
last exercise is moved for side steps
and for balance as well and it works
like this you put your feet together and
then you put your weight on one leg for
example the left one or the right
doesn't matter and then you're going to
at the same time we are going to bend
the standing leg down with its and at
the same time we are going to open the
free leg to the side like this extended
yeah I wanted to know eight each side
first woman to do this side so weight on
the left then bend the standing leg
extend the freedom and flex your foot
nothing of this here okay and then one
Bend and extend to try to keep your hips
straight yeah
don't do this yeah try to keep your hips
step three close for bend the leg extend
the three five and the leg extend three
day six then the leg extend the leg
seven go down extend the last one 8 then
the standing leg extend the free leg and
then go down to the beginning now switch
the weight to the other leg and then
we'll let's go eight more to the other
side so then the standing leg extend the
friggin one return to the start position
two and the leg extend the freedom close
three and the leg extend the village
close for then the leg extending freeman
close five then standing leg extend free
leg flex the foot close seats that
standing leg extends really close
seven then standing extent really and
eight then extend close and this was the
set for balance now I would recommend to
repeat this whole set at least twice
more that's running room so you can stop
that they repeat this block and then we
continue with the last block okay the
last block is going to be pivots is
going to be very simple and it's going
to be like this we are going to start
with the first exercise which is a
preparation for pivot and it's good for
dissociation so we start with the feet
together posture and we put our weight
on one foot
it doesn't matter which one I am on the
left and then I lift my right foot a
little bit above the floor just a few
centimeters up and I keep my two legs
really together and try to make them
open
yeah and then embrace posture and then
we're not going to people yet the only
thing we're going to do is to turn our
torso to the left then to the center and
then to the right yeah
and then to the center again yeah this
is the exercise we're going to do eight
on each leg
okay so start with the left and then one
left center right center two left
[Music]
Center right center
3 left center right center
for that center right center five there
senator
six left center right 7 left center
right center last one
8 left center right center okay so what
you need for this exercise is to keep
your core engaged and um look in your
phrasing and if you can find a spot to
fix your eyes on that helps a lot with
balance yeah
so we're going to change the weight now
I'm on the right I lift my left foot I
want to change to the woman's embrace
you remember that - yeah and then we
will do it again right center left
center to right center left
senator three right center left set for
right center left
see right senator
seven right center okay now the next one
we're going to do it so I changed my way
to the left I lift my right foot down my
brains and then we're going to do 90
degrees
pivot we start with the torso like we
did before like this and then we engage
our core an internal hip and our foot
legs and we're going to do eight so we
are going to do two full circles okay so
now I'm going to turn in the direction
of my standing leg okay so that one
breaks and then let's go
one torso clip to door Sophie three
thirty four thirty five six seven eight
yeah so one tip is when you turn the
torso and then you have to turn the hip
there is to push down with your standing
leg as if it was a screwdriver going
into the floor so you push it up this
will help you with balance now let's do
the same with the other leg so I put my
weight on there right I lift my left now
I together brace and then eight views 90
degrees one third so hip to
three door so he push down for $35 sweep
6007 door super hip eight
okay now we're going to change our
weight to the left again and now we're
going to do the people away from the
standing leg before we were doing the
people in the direction of the standing
leg now we're going to do it the OT a
little bit more difficult but it's very
useful
okay so Tom embrace straight posture
engage your core a let's go one torso
hip to toe so hip three tours of people
for don't stop him five to assume he
sees donkey seven tours of hip eight toy
sake and now let's do the same with the
other way change the weight now I'm
going to write I lift my left and take
the other embrace and then we turn away
from our standing leg okay
eight times one third so he'll two doors
so he'll three tours so cheap for tours
55 to 56 to 57 total hip eight total hip
that's it so I recommend you to do this
last block of people's two more times
more yeah to really practice your
balance understand
thank you very much I hope you like this
class and see you next time